[Music]
hello my name is Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director at the long now
foundation about seven months ago the
Pierre and Pamela a MIDI our foundation
when we asked them for a grant they
asked us to have it matched by new
membership and we set ourselves a fairly
ambitious goal of a hundred thousand
dollars in new memberships not just
renewals in in that seven months and
just twenty-four the deadline for that
was or is coming up tomorrow Saturday
night and we just reached it earlier
today so I want to thank you all and
with that I'll leave it up to Stuart to
introduce Paul thank you very much 19:59
Paul there was this assistant professor
at Stanford I was a biology major I was
studying the absolutely lowest status
subsets of biology there was in those
days which was ecology and you know all
the cool guys were going into molecular
biology we had Nobel Prize winners in
the department all that stuff but I was
hanging out with this guy who had a
Snoopy dancing around saying I love
butterflies on his door and his job was
to watch me watch tarantulas which I was
doing out at Jasper Ridge which he's
been helping protect ever since up I in
Stanford biology is the language I was
taught by Paul and others to think with
it's the best language you have ever
learned is a way to understand not only
biology but I think everything that is
interestingly complicated that was made
easier a couple years later when a
concept was Co invented by Paul and a
botanist named Peter Raven well the
concept was coevolution and I was so
charmed by the idea of coevolution which
is that
organisms spend most of their time
adapting not to the rocks and the
climate changes stuff like that they
spent almost their time adapting to each
other we're busy adapting back
we're busy adapting back to those
adaptations and you get various
convolutions and conflation subspecies
who spend really exorbitant time and
ingenuity
figuring out complicated things they do
with each other and then it becomes its
own package coevolution is such an
interesting concept to conjure with that
I wound up naming a magazine after it
coevolution quarterly that's the kind of
thing one among a great many that my
teacher Paul Eric gave me and he's here
tonight to give you some
it's hard to believe you know that we go
back 49 years and yet we're only 53
years old I don't know how the hell it
works I'm looking at the audience here
and I've discovered that their formality
at Stanford that doesn't carry over to
San Francisco so I'm going to get rid of
this damn thing and I named this book
that we're flogging at the moment the
dominant animal and I thought a lot
about that when we were giving the title
I you know should it be the dominant
organism or the dominant critter or
something like that but I always
remembered something actually you
mentioned a Nobel laureate in our
department at that time it was Josh
Lederberg and Josh said that the
survival of humanity is not preordained
and what he was thinking about is that
indeed a virus or a bacterium could very
well do all of us in it's not impossible
and right now I have a virus that's
trying to pull it off so if I fade faint
or anything else just excuse me but what
I'm gonna try and do is give you a very
brief overview of not just my view but
my view and that of the vast majority of
Mike all of my colleagues and the vast
majority of ecologists and I think the
vast majority now of biologists about
the state of the world
the genesis of this whole thing actually
goes to Stanford one of the things
that's annoyed me perpetually in my 49
years on the faculty there is that you
can get all the way through Stanford
University without having the slightest
clue about how the world works for
example we had a professor of computer
so you can do the same thing at birth me
by the way at less cost but the you know
we had a professor of computer science
who thought that milk was manufactured
and in fact most people in both
universities have no idea where their
food comes from or what's involved in
producing it worse yet they don't have
any real idea of where they came from
what the history of our species is
how we became the dominant animal and
after all if you think about it
the last couple of centuries the the
19th and 20th centuries we have taken
over the world we have first laced it
with railroads we have cleared much of
the land surface to grow crops we have
then laced it with highways we filled
the air with with jet transports and so
on and really taken over the whole damn
thing there is right now
we farm something like 15% of the
surface 12% really basically and then
there's not a 3% that's we've built on
and then there's 25% roughly that we
graze often intensively I was just in
South Africa you should see some of the
areas for instance and where there's not
a blade of grass longer than that and
another 30% of forests that we exploit
and the other remaining 30% is mostly
under ice or so high in the mountains
that we haven't managed it too much with
it yet every cubic centimeter of the
biosphere the area occupied by life has
already been modified by Homo sapiens we
have we now mobilize minerals which are
important parts of ecosystems for
industrialized society at rates higher
in general than they're mobilized by
natural processes of erosion we you may
have heard are altering the composition
of the atmosphere not necessarily to our
benefit we have spread novel chemicals
all over the entire planet at some of
them have characteristics that don't
bode particularly well for us so there's
not much question that we dominate the
planet and we've dominated it we've
gained that dominance for a series of
reasons that we partially understand I
wouldn't tell you that science knows
exactly where we came from and why and
everything that happened but what I'd
like to do now is at least briefly I'm
gonna set the bezel of my watch because
Stewart said I cannot talk more than
three hours and I don't want to run a
minute over but how do we get to be the
dominant animal with what do biologists
know
that now well one of the ways we got to
be the dominant animals we arranged for
that that asteroid or that comet to hit
the planet wipe out the dinosaurs
if we hadn't wiped out the dinosaurs we
wouldn't be here tonight it would be
Velociraptor to talking to you and a a
very different system but instead of
being tiny little things that ran around
and fed on dinosaur's eggs we've made it
to the top and the general thought is
that are something that was very much
like one of our earliest mammalian
ancestors is a tarsier which you have a
picture of here I have seen tarsiers in
the wild except have any of you ever go
into Africa and tried to see a meerkat
or something like that you're always
running you can never see get a really
good look at them well that's the way
that tarsiers are they live in bushes
and they grab insects but they move
around very very rapidly part of their
defense well what happens if you live in
bushes or trees and you eat insects well
two things that are very important in
retrospect for our dominance first of
all your eyes tend to rotate around to
the front of your heads you get good
binocular vision and then you have
digits that are able to grab things like
insects you got you can judge distance
you can grab things that's wonderful and
that's important because if we had eyes
on the side of our head we'd have had a
hard time making stone tools and things
like that or even making computers and
if we didn't have the fingers again
tough job so it was important we went up
in the trees for a while it was also
important of course that we came down
because if you're going to become a
dominant animal on the planet it's
really hard to do things like practice
agriculture without which we couldn't
have huge populations or mine minerals
and so on and so forth the trees are a
pretty limited pretty limited
environment and as many of you know the
general thought is that climate change
in Africa brought the the chimps were
envied and the and our ancestors were
partially terrestrial and as it dried
out our ancestors without under the
savannas and began to live fully
terrestrially one of the interesting
things let's see
nope wrong one I'm totally incompetent
anything technological ah there yeah and
I by the way have to be very careful
because somebody was going to stand here
and catch me if I fell off the stage
when I tried to use this but he's
chickened out he saw how big I was I
stay when one of the things to remember
about it which we don't understand why
it happened is we became bipedal before
we got big brains that was the first
step and there's still a lot of
controversy about exactly where and when
but we know for sure that the
australopithecines were bipedal and
there were probably earlier ones that
were bipedal as well so the earliest
human beings were upright small brained
hominids and I call them human beings
because we have to in other words you
cannot have for example a president the
United States who's not a hominid and so
you've got to define anything it's
upright and has a small brain as a
hominid right so see we don't really
know why our brains expanded so much so
rapidly you'll notice that they were
chimp like until you got through the
Australopithecus and then suddenly
suddenly in evolutionary time and
remember although this is about three
million years here evolutionary time is
generation time and we're sort of a long
generation organism no fruit flies have
12 days or something but human beings
have 20 years to a generation or 25 and
so in a relatively short time our brains
really expanded rapidly nobody knows for
sure why there's a lot of argument for
instance it certainly has to do with our
sociality the fact that we are
empathetic and we have a theory of mind
as chimps do and so on all ties in there
the biggest mystery because of the lousy
recordings is when languages with syntax
actually developed and there are two
general views of this one is it was
going on fairly steadily maybe from Homo
habilis to today you know from back in I
can't really see this but doesn't matter
for back in this region
today some people including my colleague
Richard Klein who is brilliant and who a
lot of this is based on thinks actually
it may have happened very very suddenly
50,000 60,000 years ago that the grunts
suddenly we became we developed syntax
which ever it was there's no question
that the thing that separates us most
clearly from all other organisms is
language with syntax as you know there
are lots of other organisms that use
tools and lots of other organisms that
get laid but the language with syntax
really does distinguish us from the
other the other organisms and I'm gonna
go to the next slide the last slide was
genetic evolution that is no question
for instance that the expansion of our
brains was tied for whatever reason into
our ability of some organ some of us to
out reproduce others there was natural
selection was functioning there our
genome was changing very rapidly but
fairly early on about two and a half
million years ago about the time of Homo
habilis we began to leave the first
signs of our culture now culture which
is non genetic information which is
passed on from generation to generation
is not unique to human beings but in
quantity is unique in other words we
have a scale of culture unknown in any
other organism chimps have culture some
birds have culture that is again non
genetic information that's passed on
from generation to generation but one of
the things we although we have a very
nice picture of how evolution occurred
genetically we still don't there's no
not yet been a Darwin for cultural
evolution we know a lot about it but we
don't really understand the mechanisms
we don't really know how to change it
for instance if if you have a problem
with a with an antibiotic for instance
and you're getting resistance to it it's
evolving a geneticist can tell you what
to do about it but if you have a problem
like a small-brained president and you
want to know how to do something about
it
there's no cultural evolution you can
say out of the thing you have to do is X
Y and see
to change it and I'll come back to that
because I think the biggest problem
humanity is facing today is
fundamentally a behavioral problem where
we don't know how actually to go about
changing it's a problem in cultural
evolution and Phi's anytime in the last
hour and a half I'll hit on that this
the thing to notice here though is that
culture evolved at a very slow rate at
first and then accelerated notices this
is not a linear scale you know it's two
and a half million years ago and fifty
thousand years ago so the first the the
Oldowan
toolkit was around for a vicinity of
eight hundred thousand years followed by
the achoo lien which was a over a
million years and they went the very
slow cultural change now there may have
been other cultural changes in records
that haven't been left but nonetheless
is a fairly good picture of an
accelerating rate of change and it
really picked up about 50,000 years ago
another big controversy about the big
leap forward Jared Diamond may have
talked to some of you about this at one
time or another but nonetheless if you
think that just fifty thousand years ago
we were still concentrating on stone
tools and bone needles and then imagine
if you were an anthropologist coming to
the remains of earth say ten thousand
years from now and you had only the
historical record that you've got by
excavating and you excavated a site from
say 1300 ad and a site from today what
would you assume you would have assumed
that organisms of an entirely different
genus had made these things in other
words the difference between the culture
the artifacts and non genetic
information which was possessed by
people in 1300 is just incredibly
different from today whereas here you
could take people sites a million years
apart and imagine it's exactly the same
organism so cultural evolution has been
accelerating at an incredible rate and
unfortunately we don't understand about
it as much as we'd like to
people have always certainly for the
last 50,000 years there's not been any
significant change in the brain power of
human beings there's no sign of that at
all and some of our ancestors as we know
from the archaeological record did
things the way some very recent people
did this is a picture I took many years
ago in the Arctic before I went to
Stanford of an Inuit showing me how they
drove huge herds of caribou over cliffs
by setting up what they call the
Inukshuk which simply means a pile of
stones it looks like a person very small
groups but they would herd the caribou
towards a funnel of these Cairns that
this is a model of one it would stand
about human size sometimes they had arms
on them of rocks sticking out and they
would have children and women behind the
every other third or fourth care and
waving blankets and the caribou will go
down either into a lake where they could
be speared from kayaks or over a cliff
or there be killed and we know that
that's exactly how a great deal of the
megafauna was wiped out in both North
America and in Europe by our ancestors
you know 15 20 thousand years ago so we
have this problem of what got us going
in certain directions after we had
developed to the point where we were
smart social animals with language with
language many people think that the big
move was the Agricultural Revolution and
there's no question at all that's we're
talking now ten thousand eight thousand
years ago in about six or seven places
around the globe people settled down and
began to practice agriculture there's no
question at all we wouldn't be here
tonight if they hadn't done it because
what agriculture did basically as it
says there don't you love people who
show you slides and then read the lines
to you as if you'd never learned to read
sorry about that I put it on to remind
me but of course the position I'm
standing I can't read it so it doesn't
make any difference at all but
agriculture had allowed people to
produce more food than they personally
needed which allowed for specialization
in the society and that's the start of
something that i call i which i think is
really important the cultural gap when I
was with the Inuit each individual knew
essentially the whole culture of the
society now there are different jobs
that for instance it was men who
crouched over the the brief breath hole
of the seal in the ice for hours waiting
for the seal to stick its head up in
spirit but the women knew how it was
done it wasn't a secret there may have
been a few secret things that the shaman
knew and so on but basically everybody
knew how everything worked and how the
society was organized and if you think
about it it's gone on and on to the
point where there isn't an individual in
this audience not an individual in this
country who possesses one millionth of
the non genetic information that our
society possesses none of us come close
you know we have 25,000 genes but a 747
has millions of parts each part is
essentially a piece of non genetic
information so one of the things that's
happened to humanity and I think it
really has consequences for us is this
enormous gap has grown where each person
can it most have a grasp of a smallest
part of our non genetic information I
admit I don't know how the damn
television set works I know if I push on
a button it lights up but that's about
the limit of another electrons racing
around in their butt and my friends who
are physicists mostly couldn't build a
television set it's not that you know
that there's some area of special
expertise so there is a big culture gap
the next big step after agriculture was
probably writing we had our language
with syntax but we were dependent on
memory basically for passing our culture
on when you start writing then you're no
longer dependent on memory things can be
passed around in personally and so on
and then came mr. Guttenberg blessedly
for those of us who are authors because
it's just held to copy all those books
out by hand and that of course opened
the culture gap that was one of the big
steps in opening the culture gap
and then of course came the Industrial
Revolution moving us towards dominance
once again and of course one of the
really big moves there you may have
heard of is that we started using solar
energy that had been gathered in the
past and stored away in the form of coal
and peat coal petroleum and natural gas
another gigantic step and one that we're
beginning to pay a very high price for
and you combine these and there's a nice
picture for mobilizing minerals I
mentioned how much we do the size of
somebody's open pit mines is absolutely
stunning to say the very least so we
aren't dominant there you are there's a
lot of nuns and much more non genetic
information in that than anybody in this
room well I don't know maybe one of you
as a clutch but alright so how do we get
to be dominant
some things we know about we're very
smart
we're very social we have developed this
incredible technological evolution that
has nothing to do with our genetics or
by the way if you think you were driven
to come here tonight to hear me because
your genes forget it there is a sort of
mythology promoted by the New York Times
and Nick Wade I think more than anybody
else that most of our everyday behavior
is controlled by our genes you know that
women have genes for low necklines and
for admiring men who drive fast cars and
on and on and on or the people as one of
my colleagues used to say are color
coded for genetic quality that was a mr.
Shockley an idiot who used to teach at
Stanford an idiot Nobel laureate who
used to teach at Stanford I say but
basically the essence of all this is our
cultural evolution that's how we got to
be dominant on the planet otherwise we'd
be chimp-like and about as dominant as
the chimps are today how many have you
ever seen chimps in the wild I'm curious
a few there they're really interesting
critters
has anybody seen bono Bo's that's my
last the ambition but they're in such
dangerous places in there so endangered
bonobos by the way are the Apes we
should be imitating our big mistake is
going chimp wise bonobos settle all of
their disputes by genital rubbing and I
think it's it's it's the coming phase
okay so we became dominant but of course
as all of you know part of the story is
that there's a cost to this dominance
and the course the dominance is that we
are without thinking about it destroying
our life-support systems and that's not
a great idea the the genius that brought
us to where we are is now threatening
our very existence am I in the if ice
move over here am i out of the TV light
either the TV lights are very bright so
I should stay stay here okay I'll look
down the the dominance is is I think
hopefully all of you realize threatening
our very existence and the reason is
that we are destroying the natural
systems of the planet that support us if
you ever hear as I just saw the other
day in the paper somebody saying in
England that you know the the economic
situation is so bad that we've got to
forget about the environment that's like
saying you know that that your hair is
falling out so rapidly that you don't
want to worry about your heart disease
the the economy is a wholly owned
subsidiary of the natural systems of the
planet they give us what are called
ecosystem services which again you can
get all the way through Stanford without
hearing the term by the way you can hear
it by going to the course which I teach
but you can't get that course required
you can get all the way through Stanford
without basically knowing anything at
all about science even though science is
and technology are at least half of our
culture by any definition so an
ecosystem service is simply something
like control of water flows maintenance
of the quality of the other gaseous
quality of the atmosphere pollination of
crops they in the United States that
supplies something
the order baseline estimate of about 17
billion dollars a year besides making
our our diet much better control of the
natural control the pests of our crops
if we didn't have that natural control
of the pests we wouldn't be eating
because we can't control crop pests if
we no matter what we try with pesticides
without killing ourselves unless we have
the backup of the natural controls on on
crop pests recycling of the nutrients
that are absolutely essential to
agriculture and forestry supplying food
food from the sea less all the time but
our less quality all the time but still
supplying it those ecosystem services
are without theirs they're invaluable we
cannot exist without them and yet they
are what we are attacking at the moment
at an enormous ly an increasing level
it's normally discussed in terms of a
little formula called the iPad equation
which simply says the impact that a
society has on its life support systems
is the function of three very ones
already Illustrated up there the number
of people you have curiously enough the
more people you have the more impact
you're going to have on your life
support systems the second thing is of
course how each person behaves a of
shall we say people who are subsistence
farmers and don't use fossil fuels at
all and so on are going to have less
impact per person in Beverly Hills
millionaires curiously enough so you
have to not just look at people often
say well the real population problem in
the world is those Indians there's more
than a billion of them you know and
that's really bad but when you look at
how people behave the most serious
population problem the world is right
here in the good old USA where we have
three hundred and two million people
we're the third largest country in the
world and numbers but when you're
multiplied in our consumption habits we
outdo everybody else at a at an enormous
level we're the most overpopulated
nation in the world interestingly enough
with three hundred two billion
well 302 million people in the US no one
has ever come up with even a semi sane
idea for why we should have more than
140 million Americans alive at one time
and the idea for why we should have a
hundred and forty million Americans
alive at one time is National Defense
because that's the number we had at the
time we we won the Second World War
now of course anybody who's nutty enough
to think that brute numbers as your
defense just has never thought about say
the Arabs and the Israelis or what a
military power India is and so on and so
forth but nonetheless that is a semi
sane reason
excuse me I need a little gin at this
point because I'm fading that's
rejuvenating uh so and then of course
besides having the the affluence factor
I pad population times affluence times
technology you also have to ask what
kind of technology and economic and
social systems supply supply the
affluence so that if what you're trying
to supply in the form of affluence is
transportation I have a very high I have
a very wonderful transportation system
for getting to work every day one of the
reasons I've stayed at Stanford is I can
walk to work and walk home and it's
absolutely wonderful if I drove an SUV
to work and back home then my the
technology factor on my impact would
obviously be very much higher so let me
talk a little bit about the things that
are affecting the iPad equation right
now I can actually say something cheery
on the population front and that is in
the last 30 years roughly we've learned
an awful lot about how to change human
reproductive behavior and it's actually
been changed over a lot of the planet
not far enough but it's been changed
them the nicest thing is it's one of
those win-win situations because the the
most important thing to do if you want
to reduce birth rates is to give rights
and opportunity to women curiously
enough if you do that birth rates come
down it's been
over a lot of the planet birth rates
have come down in Europe Japan even to a
degree in the United States although
we're still of the of the super
consuming countries about the worst but
so we have seen changes and now the
projections are that if we're lucky that
is that we don't have a huge die off or
if reproductive behavior doesn't change
in the wrong direction a will level
population size off somewhere around
probably nine billion to ten billion
people around the end of the next
century that's good news the bad news is
of course that if we go to ten billion
you're adding more than one and a half
times the number of people that were
alive when I was born in other words
adding three billion more people to the
planet we're about 6.8 now adding three
billion more people to the planet is not
only a gigantic number of people but
what you got to remember is their impact
everything else being equal is going to
be much greater than the last three and
a half billion people why is that people
are smart again we're smart animal we
became dumb we became dominant we didn't
become dominant by starting to farm the
most marginal land first and to smelt
the half percent copper ores that were
lying around on the surface what we did
was we smelted the one you know we did
we got the copper that didn't need
smelting we farmed the richest lands
first we got the easy water sources
first so every person that you add
generally needs to have water
transmitted transported further and
treated more fuels transported further
and farm a land farm that's more
marginal and requires more use of
fertilizers and so in other words this
disproportionate impact of population
growth that gets worse and worse as you
go on so that's the bad side of the
population story but it's nowhere near
as complicated as the as the bad side of
the consumption story because we haven't
really even begun to tackle the issue of
the consumption of the affluence look
we're having the the economies
staggering in various ways what
the idiot politicians say well the way
to cure this is to consume more go out
and buy another SUV buy another
refrigerator what is the consumer
spending is the big thing that keeps our
society rolling right and so the
pressure is all to increase consumption
unless you understand what's happening
to the world I have as I come back to my
recent incident on the consumption front
we have if you look at the statistics on
fisheries for example you'll see that
we've barely managed to keep the yield
up by more and more fish farming which
has terrible ecological consequences but
the fish you're getting are lower lower
quality if you look at the top three or
four fishes that were caught per decade
you see things like swordfish being
replaced by things that used to be trash
fish I used to be I used to say that one
way to tell what the state of the
fisheries was to see how many of the
fishes you were offered in a restaurant
were blackened you know when you blacken
a fish it doesn't you know it's like
blackening a Sushil a shoe sole you
can't taste the fish and so you can use
any kind of fish in a blackening
exercise or an efficient chips exercise
so the fisheries are a furry obvious
place where things have been going down
the drain and they've been going down
the drain for quite some time there's
there's a recent summary of the state of
the fisheries but it actually doesn't
show you how bad things were because all
the recent data coming in and the
studies that have been shown is that the
baseline was wrong that actually they
take it from a baseline say of around
1880 and that by that time two-thirds of
the big fishes were already gone and so
we at times you used to be able to lease
to say you could walk from Maine to
Newfoundland on the backs of the cod the
numbers are horrifying to what we've
what we've done to the oceans sorry but
of course the thing that attracts most
people's attention now on the
environmental front is what's happening
the so called global heating problem I
want to say two sort of contradictory
things about it I think and all of my
colleagues think this is an
extraordinarily serious problem
possibly quite possibly civilization
ending the conservative view of the
Intergovernmental Panel of climate
change can be said to be roughly this
that there's about a 10% chance we'll
get away with it if we were living on
Tuvalu at so we've already not gotten
away with it but by that I mean that
people in this room are not going to
directly suffer from climate change to
any significant degree and again that's
changing pretty fast too there is on the
other end of the probability spectrum
about a 10% chance that civilization
will end that because of the battles
over over resources because of
starvation and countries that are
starving having nuclear weapons and so
on that the whole thing will just go
down the drain and the other 80% of the
probability is spread in between and
nobody can be sure that's the
conservative about four or five years
ago IPCC estimate all of the data coming
in since tend to suggest that that's
much too optimistic that in fact the
positive feedbacks which are what you
don't want remember negative feedbacks
like a thermostat the more you produce
them work gets damp down positive
feedbacks the more you produce the even
more you produce and for instance the
fact that the Arctic ice is melting
people say who cares whether the Arctic
ice melts well what happens when the
Arctic ice melts it turns out ice
reflects a lot of solar energy back into
space it's got high reflectance ocean
absorbs and so the more ocean the more
Tundra and so on you have relative to
the amount of ice you have the heat the
hotter the planet gets and so there's a
very important positive feedback that
tends to indicate that the that the the
earlier estimates were in the wrong
direction
the there the IPCC works on a very slow
scale is extremely conservative because
of course it's results have to be
approved by Saudi Arabia and oil
companies and so I think it'd be very
silly to depend on it and really
important scientists like Steve
Schneider and
Jim Hansen who you may have seen in the
papers the other day are saying got to
get back to something like 350 parts per
million if we're going to have a chance
and we're going in exactly the opposite
direction at an increasing rate we're
putting more and more greenhouse gases
the atmosphere not less another problem
with a popular view of the of the global
heating problem is that the big issue is
sea level rise relaxed except if you're
in an extraordinary place or
extraordinary circumstances you'll be
able to out walk it you won't even have
to run as the sea comes up what's going
to happen of course and it's already
seems to be happening
is that the distribution of rainfall is
going to change
guess what depends on the distribution
of rainfall agriculture where we get our
food either through an irrigated system
which produces disproportionately more
than non irrigated systems or rain-fed
but you gotta have water and we're going
to be changing the distribution of water
now that may not sound so bad but it's
not gonna be a revealing of the card
some places are get wetter or someplace
where you get drier we're in training
probably something approaching a
millennium of continual change in our
patterns of water of precipitation which
means of course that our very expensive
water infrastructure is going to have to
be continually changed as Stewart and I
were talking before the meeting here
California is a hydraulic civilization
where does where's our main water supply
where is it stored somebody knows
snowpack in the Sierra what happens if
the snowpack disappears a lot of the 33
million Californians are gonna go
somewhere else I don't know where but
they're gonna have to go somewhere else
same thing in the end these Lima depends
entirely for its water on glaciers in
the Andes which are disappearing
worse yet South Asia is utterly
dependent for its water on the glaciers
in the Himalayas which are melting and
so the the problems that can be induced
by by climate change
are horrendous and we're running this
gigantic experiment to see what happens
and there are still people paid by among
others some oil companies to try and
fool people about this there was
recently you may have seen in the paper
the suggestion that they ought to be
sued the same way that the tobacco
industry was sued for lying to people
about about the effects of smoking same
kind of lying has been going on now at a
high rate and very well documented for
at least two decades by the Western
Fool's Association and other industry
groups designed to I mean you can read
their own literature the whole idea is
that make it uncertain to put
uncertainty and to make people under the
science doesn't prove it well science
never proves anything but I think what
you have to do is read the newspapers to
see what's happening on the climate
change front this may not be our most
serious environmental problem that's the
horrible thing and I'll come back to
some of the others well what do you want
you didn't come here to be cheered up
did you for Christ's sake toxification
of the planet maybe it's related to
consumption of course crap we put on our
farm fields or our big monocultures
but toxification maybe a worse problem
why and I'm not sure yes or no
but we've spread toxic substances all
over the planet and at least with
climate change we've got crackpot ideas
for what to do if we can't get the
greenhouse gas emissions down we're
gonna dump billions of tons of iron
filings in the Southern Oceans we're
gonna put sunshades between us in the
Sun we're gonna have the battleship
Missouri shooting air saul's into the
atmosphere you know five shots a minute
for the next 200,000 years that sort of
thing now these aren't nutty they're
truly nutty but at least you know people
can think about what you might possibly
do by the way most of them don't do
anything at all for the acidification of
the oceans that comes from the carbon
dioxide no you don't want to think of
the greenhouse gases only having the
effect of changing the way the heat is
transferred in the in the atmosphere but
with the toxic
what do you do get your graduate
students out there with forceps to pull
the molecules back out of the world the
DDT that's in the Arctic ice cap in the
end the Arctic ice and in the Antarctic
ice and so on and some of the things
we're releasing in quite large
quantities are things that don't have a
standard dose response curve this the
one of the things that's wrong with our
regulations is the assumption it's
always made that the more of a chemical
you have are exposed to the worse the
effects but there are a lot of things
for the things that mimic hormones where
that can be exactly reversed that the
smaller amounts are much more deadly and
it's because it has a way it depends on
how the receptors that are affected are
upregulated or downregulated and there
are many substances if you're exposed to
very small parts you get really nasty
results and you don't get those results
if you're exposed to big doses
now you may how many of you know the
story of bisphenol A just curious a few
of you all right
whether this this I think shows how
linnaeus miss named us Homo sapiens the
smart man that was the original name
what smart man would work very hard to
develop a synthetic hormone to use in
things like birth control pills estrogen
and find out it's not quite powerful
enough to use in the pills so you put it
into the plastic a baby bottle so it
leeches into the baby's milk fur not
very Homo sapiens is it but almost all
these hard plastic sports bottles are
giving you all a dose of hormones which
may actually be more effective at small
doses than large we don't know so when I
say that the problem of toxification may
be worse there are these weird signs for
instance in subarctic villages in some
places now there are twice as many girl
babies born as boy babies and there are
stories of I shouldn't say stories there
are reports of decline in sperm
viability in men that there's a move
towards less less viable sperm now these
are very controversial but the point is
when you start dosing everybody with
weird hormones
in combinations you have no idea what
the effects are going to be if you find
out one of them is really bad there's
not even a crackpot scheme to come up
with to cure it you can't get rid of it
it's all over the environment we are
releasing thousands and thousands of
chemicals into the environment where we
have NOAA we have little idea of their
direct effect on human beings no idea of
their effect on other organisms and no
ideas of their of their synergistic
possible synergistic effects 1-way 2-way
3-way n minus 1 over n times n minus 1
over 2 ways you have a lot of
interactions if you have 10,000
chemicals out there no way you can test
them and I think obviously some of these
things we need to do when others what
kind of society we have you can't avoid
letting some stuff out into the
environment but you sure as hell can
avoid putting synthetic hormones into
your plastics that they're going to leak
out of it's like the issue of and some
of you will disagree with me no doubt
but of animal experimentation I think I
much rather have a surgeon who trained
on a dog operating on my granddaughter's
heart than a surgeon who learned it on
the computer ok that's my personal view
but I think there's no excuse at all for
taking rabbits cutting off their eyelids
and testing the toxicity of mascara on
there was a difference between an open
heart operation for a kid and the safety
of mascara which I'm told you can
actually live without so but but I mean
so basically we're we're dumping all
kinds of crap that we don't necessarily
have to or don't have a high enough
standard for what you order what might
be safe enough to release because you
get such a huge benefit from it that the
risk can be written off and so on we
don't really think about these things
systematically which i think is a very
bad idea I'm blabbering on I better get
moving ah Mike and and I when when we
were courting in Lawrence Kansas
unbelievable place it's absolutely one
thought absolutely flat but
intellectually it is the
was we go to a Passion Pit how many if
you're old enough to remember what a
Passion Pit is hey there are a few of us
here a drive-in movie it used to be able
use to be able to go to the movies in
your car and not get out of the car and
you could do all kinds of other
interesting things in the car when the
movie got really dull right well well
we're we're doing this in in the in the
nineteen fifty in the 1950s they'd come
around with something like that and
blast it in your car window to keep the
mosquitoes down you know DDT or some
other wonderful compound that you didn't
have to worry about
and now DDT is over the entire planet I
don't have to give you their the routine
on toxic wastes or to move on from
toxification another thing we do besides
toxifying the planet is moving organisms
all over the planet without worrying
about the consequences that's a picture
of the vine that ate the south I don't
know if you know about kudzu but there's
just lots and lots of problems created
by just carrying things around curious
enough another big environmental problem
and you know I want to keep the cheer
going here so naturally I move right
onto the Black Death but again one of
the things we're not preparing for we're
actually moving in the wrong direction
on is the the epidemiological
environment think about it for a minute
what controls the chance of getting vast
epidemics particularly of novel
pathogens well one is how many people
you have first of all the novel
pathogens are all things that are
generated normally or I shouldn't say
all mostly generated in other organisms
so the things like Marburg virus and
AIDS and so on came as transfers from
natural hosts into us now the more
people you have the more people are
pressed into contact with the natural
hosts the more people you have the
better the chance that a transfer will
actually occur and will take and the
more people you have the better the
chances the disease will become
established in human beings for instance
if you you can't have measles perm
in a city of less than 50,000 people and
the reason is that everybody either dies
or becomes immune and the disease dies
out you got to have big populations to
support many pathogens well we have
guess what huge population biggest we've
ever had on the planet
second thing that we have is very large
numbers or probably at least a billion
people who are immune compromised
because they don't have adequate diet at
least down to the micronutrient level
then what have we added to this very
rapid transport systems think about it
if a plague ship left Japan bound for
India nobody India got plague because
everybody died or became immune on the
ship long before I got the India whereas
there was one steward who infected
people with AIDS on four continents in
one week so we have very rapid transport
systems added into the whole picture and
then of course for bacterial diseases
were disarming ourselves because we have
so misused antibiotics that even the
antibiotic now of last resort vancomycin
people are showing a strains are showing
up that of various bacteria that are
resistant to vancomycin
so we're disarming ourselves at the same
time there's no programs in any
government that I know of really
adequately stacking antiviral medicines
there are no programs for quarantine for
instance when I got scarlet fever when I
was a kid they put a big sign on the
door of the house quarantine my parents
couldn't go anywhere nobody could come
in and so on we should be prepared at
the national level at the local level
and so on for quarantine we don't have
enough hospital beds a another viral
plague like the flu in 1918 1919 which
killed more people in the first world
war is a real possibility with even
bigger results in a larger population
with much more rapid transport and so on
so another thing that we should be
worrying about that we're not we
actually have been at defunding the CDC
pretty much over time is there and I
just I came back from an and Iran's
other in Africa as I mentioned last week
for a few days ago and one of our
colleagues somebody that Stewart knows
also teaches there in the U
versity of pretoria and he's trying to
develop capacity and biology and
conservation and so on in African
students and he says he'll have this
wonderful class of really bright eager
students and he realized as a 25% of
them are gonna be dead in a few years
towards the rate that level of AIDS
infection is absolutely horrifying there
is a little good news on that front if
true that there has been a decline in
new infections but Africa is in deep
deep trouble and of course it's the is
gonna be a lag time in seeing the
results and one of the true but a lot of
Africa is a very sad place we ran to a
lot of people from Zimbabwe which is
being ruined by a single person and I
have a graduate student working now in
Kenya and Stewart and I and will spend
time in Kenya a wonderful country that's
been driven under by a relatively few
people in in insanely actually so and
the president in South Africa isn't a
big help on the AIDS front so I'm not
I'm not overly optimistic about what
will happen in Africa except the people
are wonderful it's a wonderful continent
well and then of course we have the
problem in our consumption area about
about resource Wars because we're in the
middle of the first big one now a the
the the first short one of course was
the Israeli Arab world over water in
1967 if you know the history of it if
you though it's in it's in the book but
the one we have now goes back to the
time when Churchill decided to switch
the Royal Navy to oil and that was the
time that the then the British the
French the Russians and as late comers
the United States divided up the Middle
East and made countries on the basis of
oil deals the bucco Bank Ian agreement
the redline Agreement all that stuff
which some of our government people
never heard of before they decided to
try and get their hands on Iraq s-- oil
the my colleague Gretchen Daly I think
summarized it very well when all of us I
think probably most of the people in
this room were arguing against the idea
of invading Iraq to get its oil she said
do you suppose that we be planning to
invade Iraq if their major export were
broccoli and it turns out probably not
but it just came out I mean finally the
New York Times which has had this long
slumber on the Iraq war you know
remember they were big promoters over
slowly came out and admitted the other
day that it's all for oil buy of course
what's-his-name the head of Lee the X
head of the SEC admitted it long before
that what's his name
come on somebody Greenspan yeah
Greenspan see when you get old enough
your synapses just disappear yeah well
of course oil was a big factor in the
first and second world war we fought
over it in both of those wars here's a
nice sign of when you're thinking about
why it's so wonderful to have three
hundred and two million Americans the
American press did not mention as far as
I can determine one word about the
downside of having three hundred and two
million people we were congratulating
ourselves for having gone over three
hundred - mmm reminded of the old saying
you know you should never worry about
the population being too small because
it can be enlarged by unskilled labor
that loves its work and there there's US
oil dependency guess what you know if we
only had 140 million people today guess
how much we wouldn't be importing from
the Middle East and guess how much less
greenhouse gases there would be in the
atmosphere other words have any of you
seen anything in the mass media that has
pointed out that population size is a
major factor in the climate change
situation they are just this I want to
put some numbers in so you'll feel that
you've heard a technical seminar but
more important think about it if you do
the calculations roughly roughly 50% of
our military expenditures are designed
to to keep control over oil how you do
the calculation depends on what you feel
about how much of it is designed to beat
China out and the Caspian Basin if you
think we're building these fancy jet
fighters and so on to fight al-qaeda
think
again those our military is planning to
fight China don't forget their
military's planning to fight us too
because China's running out of oil I'll
go through some of the there's CENTCOM
and why should the United States have
one of its major military areas covering
that is it because we're desperately
interested in saving sand or something
uh not clear I think it must be oil and
there's the Caspian Basin with giant
reserves and if you're interested more
about resource Wars it's actually
something that is not much in the
newspapers but has been very thoroughly
discussed in the literature and here's a
good book on it by Michael Clare and
just some historical stuff on the cat
the the arab-israeli war in 67 but for
tomorrow place after place particularly
in the Middle East has got huge
population growth little water and
almost certain fights over it just like
there's going to be it's almost certain
more fights after we finish with Iraq
and maybe Iran in the in the CENTCOM
area we're gonna try and stabilize oil
flows this is the the techie part of the
talk I won't even read you the
as some years ago Dennis courageous of
political scientists and I in 1972 got
an op-ed in to the New York Times
entitled what if all the Chinese got
wheels at that time there was 500
million Chinese now there 1.3 billion
how many of you been to Beijing what I
don't need to tell you yeah they don't
have any garages but they sure guide
cars is this is some computer nut who's
wasted huge amounts of my time that's
its little you know when when when
windows crashes you can think of that
this guy
alright what are we gonna do about all
this that's that that's the end of the
light show and it's really the end of my
time but I'm gonna say that if the
situation isn't that we can't do
anything about this what you can say for
sure is there are no silver bullets in
other words if you wanted to change the
way we behave then you're gonna have to
change the design of our cities you're
going to have to dramatically change our
sources of energy and how much we use
we're gonna have to make dramatic steps
to try and preserve what remains of the
biodiversity that's necessary to run our
ecosystem services it's basically a
wedge approach you've got to do
thousands of things that are going to
move us in the right direction why
aren't we doing them there are lots of
reasons besides a total lack of
leadership but we really don't
understand many of them and that's why
my own research is going more and more
into cultural evolution because we've
got to understand how to change human
behavior and and I with a whole bunch of
other people scattered around the world
who are interested in in fact I'm going
to go talk to the Norwegian government
about it in a couple of months are
trying to design not another millennium
ecosystem assessment how many of you
ever heard of the Millennium ecosystem
service it's a assessment that's
interesting good thousands of scientists
got together over the last five six
years to determine what is the state of
our life-support systems and you can
read their summary paragraph but if you
really want to know when you want to
know fast go into your bathroom you
probably have a porcelain thing on the
floor lift the lid look down in and push
the lever and you'll know what's
happening to our life-support systems
it's better than the executive summary
and what we need is a millennium
assessment of human behavior how to get
the kind of discussion we're having here
tonight which is unknown to 99% of the
people in the world much more broad how
to get people listening to something
besides if any of you ever heard of of
the fox news channes are very
interesting phenomenon in science it's
connected with agriculture you all know
about concentrated animal feeding
operations k foes this is where you put
10,000 hogs in a room this
and outside you have 50 acres of hog
feces fermenting and geysering and
eventually breaking through the dam and
pouring down the river so you have this
absolute flood of hog feces going down a
river you know what scientists call that
Fox News effect that's right now see
somebody's keeping up with the
literature people have got to understand
what's going on and scientists can't
tell them what to do scientists can give
them a fair idea of what the
consequences of various courses will be
but we don't want a world designed by
scientists I know too many of them but
we've got to somehow get the discussion
going and I think that's the big
challenge for the future and in part and
we got to get the social scientists
better organized to help us understand
why we do the things we do if I want to
give you some hope it is that and I've
said this to many audiences one thing we
do know about cultural evolution is it
can change with incredible rapidity when
the time is ripe think about how the
Second World War changed the status of
minorities in the United States changed
the status of women in the United States
think a more recent example none of us
I don't know anybody including senators
and so on who had any idea that the
Soviet Union would break apart and
basically communists would endow
communism would end over most of the
countries there was it happens suddenly
we don't understand why but we do know
then that we could change dramatically
we could begin paying real attention to
how we treat each other and how we treat
our environment it's possible we know it
can happen the issue is how do we make
it happen how do we ripen the time for
that to happen you've been very patient
thank you
thank you Paul mind if I shut this down
on you you said you were gonna there was
some incident you were going to tell us
about having to do with consumption that
you were gonna keep till the third oh oh
yeah no III yeah I'm sorry but of course
my mind is gone the I was doing a radio
a TV blog show for a New York Times
reporter yesterday and he says look is
there any reason to should we really
keep any wilderness at all in other
words is the existence of a noir has a
relatively undisturbed area and remember
it's only relatively undisturbed the
whole planet has been disturbed by us is
that a good reason to to keep from
drilling for oil there and I said I
don't care whether Anwar is loaded with
wonderful organisms or an absolute
destroyed desert I wouldn't drill for
oil there or anywhere else it's
absolutely nuts to be drilling for oil
when it's a resource we shouldn't be
burning we should be getting off by
killing our kids and many many thousands
of Iraqis to get oil a resource we
should be facing away from is absolutely
insane
you just he'd never thought of that you
know Anwar was do you drill for oil or D
in that drill for oil we're not running
out of fossil fuels you get rid of the
oil we have so much cold so much tar
sand and so what we're running out of is
environment we have no place to dump the
co2 and I don't believe most of the
plans to sequester it and they're not
going anywhere anyway so that was the
the incident the fact that a very
knowledgeable person who was very
environmental and very friendly had
never occurred to him that the idea for
drilling in Anwar is insane because it's
drilling not because of the
characteristics of Anwar which adds to
the insanity of course Paul I want to
keep you over here in the lone I'm sorry
camera guy sir the other eye they're
going nuts yeah okay you want me to
repeat the okay yes I have a bad back
too and I've got to move around okay
Raman slow
where's Rob you wanna dance
can't wait question says okay let's say
we get a present with a larger brain
easy comes into office in January and
summons professor Erlich to the White
House for advice what's your number one
policy priority that you recommend to
this person my number my number one
what's important and what's achievable
okay well I think that it's perfectly
achievable the number one priority ought
to be to generate the start of a
millennium assessment of human behavior
that is get up and give a speech and say
the most important things in our society
are not whether or not gays can get
married or whether which starlet happens
to be wearing her panties today there
are these issues like survival food bla
bla bla bla why we're fighting in Iraq
and we got to start a national
discussion of it in other words I think
because hated as we are overseas and one
of the terrible things I'm sure many of
you travel overseas and though it is our
reputation is you know in the dumper and
but despite that everybody envies us and
looks to us so if for example the
president got up and said something
really weird like every economist I know
thinks gasoline prices are too low
that's true for me it's probably true
for any economist you run into my
colleague Larry Gould ER who's chair of
our economics department at Stanford now
I spent many years trying to answer the
following question if you get rid of the
externalities and raised by taxing the
gas the gasoline prices somewhere in the
vicinity say of bottled water that how
do you keep the poor people still able
to get to work in a society that hasn't
yet redesigned its its cities and the
answer is fairly simple and what's
called tax shift and you take the huge
revenue that came in from you know
raising the gas tax to say two bucks a
gallon so you're gradually so you're at
six or seven dollars a gallon and you
pay down the F I see a tax which is
regressive it's not all that complicated
but if somebody in the u.s. got up the
president got up and said we got to find
ways to raise the price of gasoline
you'd know something was happening
instead of you you may not believe this
I know but let me tell you I was told
that one presidential candidate followed
by another said we ought to take the
pathetic little gas tax we have off so
Americans can burn even more oil and
make even more rapid climate change I
know I know you don't believe that but I
think it can be documented one of those
already lost in the other one will I
hope that's an omen we'll see you've
been talking about culturally evolution
but you're actually studying this as I
understand that there's something about
Polynesian canoes and I wish you would
report what you've got there well
scientists like to see if you can get
down to some very basic ideas using
simple systems and one of the things
that I think you've probably all noticed
and I sort of talked about it here is
that our cultural evolution in the area
of Technology has been going on
extremely rapidly whereas cultural
evolution in areas like ethics has it I
mean it's changed but if you think about
it if any of your philosophers a lot of
the problems that worried Plato are
still worrying us today okay whereas how
to feed the camels is not a big issue in
our society at the moment so the issue
is the question that I wanted to answer
is do parts of culture that are tested
against the environment evolve more
rapidly or more slowly than ones that
aren't is there a difference and one of
the problems with understanding cultural
evolution I hate to tell you is it's
extremely hard to get data the
historians don't keep data it's very
hard to compare things so I thought we'd
go and look at Polynesia why would one
pick Polynesia as a test system for the
same kind of reasons that one uses
Escherichia coli the gut bacterium for
studying genetics it's a simple system
Polynesia is simple from the point of
view that it's the place where human
beings have been the shortest time
basically the whole invasion took place
and since in AD
and we know the sequence in which the
islands were populated pretty well from
genetic studies and from from
archeological studies and so on and
there isn't the problem of mixed
migrations going on all the time there
was established the Polynesian societies
and then in the 1700s there was one
European flush that came through and
acculturated the whole thing so I
thought that what would I do
I thought I would study I would take a
look Oh
another advantage the islands are
beautiful and wonderful anthropologists
aren't dumb and so every anthropologists
want to get a PhD went out landed on one
of these islands enjoyed the topless
women and wrote an ethnography so I
thought ok we'll I'll get the
ethnographies and I'll check which
changed more rapidly as the islands were
invaded the agricultural techniques
highly tested against the environment
and we know a lot about them and the
number of God's not tested against the
environment at all but presumably we
know about them too it turned out that
the ethnographies are written like
novels they had mentioned Rango is a God
but they wouldn't mention whether dango
was there too and they'd say yeah they
grow this crop but they wouldn't give
proportions of the crops and other ones
that weren't there turn out to be
hopeless to gather the data just about
to give up and I found a two-volume said
of the canoes of Oceania in which they
actually had tables of data it needed a
lot of working but I got a brilliant
graduate student I we
important thing for faculty members to
know is you've got to have young
graduate students to steal ideas from
first of all but second of all this was
a woman is a woman who we let in at the
age of 50 and there was a lot of
discussion about whether or not it was
fair to her to bring her into graduate
school at the a at the age of 50 which
turned out to be the best graduate
student I've laid eyes on in a long long
time completely housebroken none of the
problems that the 23 year old graduate
studies have and she massaged these data
and we were able we were able to compare
the structural features of the canoes
and how rapidly they changed and the
decorative features of the canoes which
are presumably not really tested against
the environment well the interesting
thing is when I first started talking
about I said because of that background
that I gave you it's over the overall
thing between ethics and I said I
suspect that the things tested against
the environment will evolve more rapidly
because if you're running a cart with a
square wheel and somebody comes up with
a hexagonal wheel the square wheels gone
and then somebody comes up with a
octagonal wheel yeah and so on and she
said yeah but when you get to the round
wheel progress will stop aha you know
and we actually talked about this a lot
and couldn't come to any conclusion but
it turned out that the data in let's ask
the audience with their help oh yes
so this said think about it for a minute
which is going to change faster the
elements of culture which are basically
forced by the environment you know the
panel shape or how the canoe is put
together or things which are pretty much
just culture having its own good time
the colors on the canoe the colors on
the paddles stuff like that how many
think it'll be forced by the changes
will mainly come from environmental
forcing maybe a third I'm going to think
it'll just wander around because culture
doesn't care maybe - that was the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences now support the latter group in
trying to explain this retrospectively
partly Deborah was correct
that is namely and when you get a
functional design that works there
there's less pressure to change it but
the other thing we think and we haven't
this is pure speculation is that people
like to differentiate themselves they're
not going to differentiate themselves by
putting the wings on the airplane
straight up so the airplane falls out of
the sky they're gonna paint it a
different color and so I think there's a
tendency to this is let me tell you
something else interesting that I didn't
really I remember I saying genetics
doesn't explain all this stuff one of
the reasons we know that genetics
doesn't explain our everyday behavior
genetic differences is for instance the
dye on quintuplets which some of you may
remember these are identically identical
five I genetically identical little
girls who clothing raised they were
literally raised in a laboratory
literally raised in a laboratory by a
psychologist and they had completely
different life stories
same thing with Chang and Aang the the
Siamese twins more cloning yeah one was
it one was a drunk and the other was
sober one was conservative the other was
liberal and so on I by the way I would
love to have a sober Siamese twin think
about it you share circulation with them
you get drink twice as much before you
go have sex but and they're yelling in
your ear the whole time yeah but having
said that the interesting thing is where
do the differences come from kids raised
in a laboratory with the same genes turn
out to be extremely different to people
who were joined by a band of flesh that
big for their entire lives turned out to
be entirely different even though they
had identical genomes and we don't know
the answer to that except one of the
clear reasons is and and this is
something again that we're trying to
look into is that most of us including
biologists think you know there's some
fun there's ejaculation there's
fertilization and then nine months later
a baby appears right mm-hmm but it turns
out the more we learned those nine
months are filled with all kinds of
doses of hormones and the fetus able to
understand that wreck
the mother's voice and so on and so
forth I think we're ignoring a huge
chunk of human development interpreting
the results as being genetic when
actually their environmental but
environmentally in the womb no there's
other things in there too and what
triggered me on that is maybe Chang and
Eng became so different because nailed
together they have the urge to
individuate to be comfort more different
yeah so we don't really know that but it
shows how ignorant we are of really
critical things in human development
another question on cultural evolution
this one from Kevin Kelly some reason he
selected his question the end of me do
you have any evidence that cultural
evolution is either predictable or
engineering and what if aggregate
cultural behavior is truly stochastic
much like if aggregate cultural
evolution is truly stochastic we're
screwed it's that simple
we we either going to understand I don't
think it is I think that you can see all
kinds of patterns in history that tell
you it's not stochastic in other words
it's stochastic at one level just like
genetic evolution is often well yeah
what are some of the patterns in genetic
evolution that are of the kind of
pattern see we'd look to find and
cultural evolution well in in genetic
evolution well it's it's like we were
just talking about with the canoes
basically that's a form of selection
that is the people who put the canoe
together without caulking the seams
around and so that form of making canoes
did not did not get passed on culturally
but if you think about it there I
actually we have a nice example in the
in the book of how in this between the
first and second world war all the
armies in Europe modernized basically
intellectually except the British the
British Army was the last army that was
basically a peasant levee led by
aristocrats and the requirements of the
aristocrats is they had to be neat clean
smell good stand upright and have good
manners but they didn't have to be
bright and as a result
a lot of the British leadership early in
the war but in the desert war was just
horrendous and the they they for
instance they are very conservative they
stuck with their regiment of the
regiment was the thing in the British
Army and it turned out the regiment was
the wrong unit to use in the desert and
the Germans Rommel who wasn't so
constrained beat the hell out of them
for a while there was one British
general and you talk about so castus ISM
the guy named O'Connor who was really
good but he ran into a German unit
behind his own lines by mistake was
captured and the British paid a very
high price for it if you look at I enjoy
looking at military history because I'm
I think like most scientists I think if
you want to understand a substance or a
system you want to look at it under
stress and you know war puts human
beings in various forms under all kinds
of of stress I add one of the places I
had a knife is climate change will be
good for us because it'll put us under
stress I won't tell you about ich
lawanda and Rorke's drift where we were
last week yeah one of the things you've
been doing course is telling us what
things to worry about and that's makes
it a tough evening I also tell you to go
out and drink afterwards because you can
keep your internal environment in good
shape while your external goes down the
drains your gin he receives a lot of my
fellow environmentalists are deeply
worried about genetically engineered
foods especially with genetically
engineered crops in general you're an
ecologist this is a bad thing oh well
first of all I I it blanket condemnation
like that is not a good idea we've been
eating genetically engineered crops for
thousands of years and we were lucky
they're genetically engineered because
one of the things we do in the
engineering for instance the ancestors
of cucumbers were loaded with the Kerkar
potations which are nasty poisons and we
selected the mouth so we can eat the
cucumbers on the other hand blankets
saying it's all good
not necessarily you stick a peanut gene
into a cucumber and people who have
peanut allergy
so it's like any other technology it's
like the nuclear arguments you can't say
nuclear power is good or bad there's
some potential good in it there's some
potential bad in it it all depends in
part on who controls it and who deploys
it I mean it's it's so III we are stuck
using technology and high technology if
we're going to solve these problems
we're not in a position to go back to
hunting and gathering or subsistence
agriculture but we the system we have
for examining the technologies for the
interface between the politics and the
technology and so on is very bad there
shouldn't be a nuclear industry
screaming that we've now got to build
more nuclear plants there should the big
mistake we made with nukes was that and
it was it was a good mistake in a sense
the scientists who built the new the
atomic bomb felt really guilty and I
think for I'm not saying they were
guilty but it was a good reason if I'd
been involved I probably would have
worked on it but I wouldn't have been
thrilled by the results at all and they
wanted to show that actually the work
they had done was gonna be a huge
benefit to humanity so we were gonna
have energy too cheap to meet
electricity too cheap the meter and all
that sort of thing and what we did was
instead of carefully designing reactors
to produce power we immediately because
of the situation with the Russians
carefully designed reactors to run
submarines now submarines have to be as
small as possible to avoid detection and
so we got reactors with huge power
densities that is trying to get a huge
amount of energy out of a small machine
and almost by definition if somebody's
doing that you know it's going to be
more dangerous than something it's
designed to operate safely for a very
long time so we deployed all these
submarine reactors refitted sort of for
commercial use and that led to public
relations extravaganzas like Three Mile
Island and Chernobyl and so on and so I
the technically skeptical community
thinks that you can have safe nuclear
power if you do it right the issue is
can we do it right
and that's you know particularly because
you got to do it right for a very long
time the Atomic Energy Commission
guaranteed that it would guard plutonium
for something like 10 half-lives to make
sure that it was safe which was 500,000
years I think they guaranteed to to
sequester the plutonium for 500,000
years that was two years before the
Atomic Energy Commission won't
disappeared
I mean you Hugh manatee has not got a
great record for doing things exactly
right like using the Missouri to shoot
air souls into the atmosphere for the
next 10,000 years and so on and so and
in fact nathan keyfitz a very famous
demographer once said though the most
certain finding of the social sciences
is you can count on bad policies badly
administered which tells you you've got
to build some buffering into the system
I think that's correct but doesn't mean
you don't do anything
it means you sort of make the system's
super failsafe so or actually somebody I
hate dr. Strangelove said what's this
thing you know I'm trying to remember
the guy with the yellow with the metal
leg I was gonna plug him into a pit no
no not fun knowing then the guy who
built the hydrogen bomb tell her tell
her
said a fool of sufficient magnitude can
be found to overwhelm any foolproof
system and I think it's another good so
related to that then here's a question
from Ralph what's wrong okay is there a
single invention that you have recently
witnessed that makes you optimistic
about our future I guess no and the
reason is I don't think there's any
single invention that could do it okay
if you wanted to ask me if I could just
give us an invention that would make our
lives a lot simpler it would be a cheap
easily disposable in a recycling sense
and very long live battery but again you
get into the same kinds of things that
you get into with the nuclear
powerplants if you imagine you know a
battery this big that will run your car
just imagine how dangerous it's going to
be when you pack that you know the laws
of thermodynamics are not going to
change and you pack huge amounts of
energy into a small space you better be
damn careful about how you're doing it
it sounds like part of what you're
saying about technology is the Devils in
the details
that it is you know now you know nuclear
or or genetic engineering you know as a
whole subject you don't know yet you got
to find out this is a good reactor band
reactor you know gonna be a Luddite I
mean what's the classic example in this
area better things for better living
through chemistry remember the the
freons
were developed by by DuPont hmm and it
was a marvelous thing before the freons
if your refrigerator sprung a leak in
the middle of the night you were dead
because the ammonia came out you were
you're gone when he switched the freons
you were perfectly safe the refrigerator
sprung a leak and all it did was there
food spoil of course it could have
destroyed civilization because when we
finally found out what was happening to
the ozone hole you know the life only
was able to come out of the oceans 400
million years or so ago because we had
an ozone layer that protected us from
the UVB and so there is no such thing as
a permanently safe technology you've got
to be watching it all the time and with
the kind of pricky with the kind of
technologies we have to deploy with our
kind of society so it's pointless being
a Luddite we can't survive without
really good technologies and we ought to
have very careful ways in which we allow
the political system to interact with
the technologists it's it's a two-way
thing that has to be controlled from
both ends the technologists always want
to push the envelope I remember being in
the debate with some British physicists
in a in London and we're talking about
energy systems and I was saying look you
know one good way to heat water is with
solar energy and they were saying no
fusion is the way they go and I finally
dawned on me why they were saying that
you know if you heat water by putting a
50 gallon drum on your roof
painting it black and piping cold water
into the bottom and into the bottom and
taking hot water off the top that's not
very technologically sophisticated but
for fusion you gotta have magnets that
are almost absolute zero within feet of
a plasma which is the temperature of the
surface of the Sun that's an interesting
problem and the technologists are you
can't blame them might be the same way
you always want to push in that
direction but the politicians have to
have enough technological knowledge to
say yeah that's fine they're there we're
not going to give you the money we're
going to put the 50 gallon drum on the
roof and one last question you're still
still got ecology students basically
some of them are 50 something and all
the better and I guess part of my you
deployed me out to Jasper Ridge a
relatively pristine relatively pristine
area Outback of Stanford is it fair to
wonder what the ecologists would be
finding if they're focusing on the
cities now since we're gonna we've got
to design them better as you say if they
were focusing on agriculture as
ecologists which we've got to design
those systems better so the ecology
isn't hurt by how the agriculture works
is that going on with your students now
is it something that should be having
both I don't have any students directly
at the moment working on cities but our
entire group has focused basically on
what's called countryside biogeography
move on which is and and the natural
capital project that Gretchen Daly is
running which is asking questions like
this how do you design areas already
very disturbed by human beings in
agriculture or something so that you can
maintain the biodiversity that supplies
the pollination services the the pest
control services and so on Gretchen's
whole group which involves a lot of
people in finance and so on is how do
you align financial incentives with
conservation incentives to preserve the
ecosystem services which are generally
not priced and economics plays a huge
role I mean the last 20 years the cheery
a thing I can say is that ecologists and
as have come together my Larry Golder is
now maybe my closest single colleagues
not even our department chairman of
economics I spend more time working with
economists on these issues we we
published a paper great I'll just go to
them or did the Economist both really
well actually Parthenon scooped and
economists came to Stanford on leave and
actually started a lot of it because he
had read eco science and things like
that but we we get along very well we
see the same problems and we actually
got a paper published with Ken arrow who
was agreed to be the world's smartest
economist Nobel laureate as the lead
author entitled are we consuming too
much gigantic breakthrough but what we
heard was really funny is published by
the leading economics journal United
States and one of the editors said we
heard that we've got to publish this
paper by Ken arrow and his communist
colleagues I rest my case on that note
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you